[BLANK_AUDIO]
>> Okay, so I think I have a handle on optimizing
HTML and CSS. So, are we moving on to the render tree?
>> Almost, we haven't really talked about JavaScript,
and obviously that's an important step, so let's
take a look at that. Okay, well let
me guess, minify it, compress it and cache it?
>> Yup. All of those are good strategies. But for JavaScript you may have seen
piece bit insighs also complain about parser
blocking scripts. Let's take a look at what
that means and how we can optimize it.
I've extended our hello world page with
a simple inline script at the bottom. Let's
walk through it. First of all, we reach into the DOM and look for the first
span element. Which, as you can see, contains
the web performance text. Next, we modify the
DOM element by changing its inner text and
also changing its CSS properties. Seems simple enough.
>> Yeah, this shows that JavaScript can manipulate
both the DOM and the CSS Object Model. It's
a very powerful tool. And it gets a
bit more interesting from here. Next, we create a
new div element, set its text content. CSS
caller property, and append it to the page. Let's
try to load this page on our phone. Notice
that the text now says, Hello interactive students instead
of Hello web performance students. And we also have our new element right below
it. Right, as expected. So is there
anything here we can do to optimize performance?
>> Definitely, optimizing JavaScript could be an entire course. But,
in this particular example, it's not really the code, but how
it's included on the page. Let's take a step back and
think about how the browser would go about building this page